alexandre kateb est le fondateur du site
de multiples hariti report selon lui
alger veut éviter que le conflit libyen
ne déborde sur son territoire l'algérie
en fait à jouer c'est un peu ce rôle de
médiateur
refusant de s'engager vis-à-vis de l'une
des parties tout en faisant attention à
ce que des lignes rouges sera franchi la
ligne rouge principal bien entendu c'est
la souveraineté territoriale l'intégrité
territoriale de l'algérie qui partage
une frontière avec avec ses différents
pays notamment avec la libye est donc
forcément il ya eu la sphère de la plate
forme gazière à l'époque donc en 2013 ou
terroristes s'étaient infiltrés depuis
la libye donc l'algérie doit éviter à
tout prix
qui est cette contagion en fait du
conflit libyen sur son territoire la
russie elle est engagée de manière plus
évidente aux côtés du maréchal haftar
néanmoins aspire aussi à une
régularisation de ce conflit on va aussi
de ses intérêts notamment économique
dans la région